I think everyone wants to be an
astronaut at some point when they're
young the problem with us is that we
never stop wanting to be an astronaut
this mission was put together to try and
answer this question about me thing
people believe they observed methane in
the atmosphere of Mars methane is a
really interesting gas because it really
shouldn't be there the instrument on the
orbiter is called a nomad it actually
consists of three spectrometers
spectrometers essentially look at the
light from the Sun measure the
wavelengths no maybe we'll look at the
sunlight through the Mars atmosphere by
looking at the colors that are absorbed
we can figure out what gas is present in
the atmosphere so methane is obviously
one of these gases has a very specific
absorption band so a very specific color
will be missing the exomars mission as a
whole consists of two parts the first is
this 2016 orbiter which looks at the
atmosphere from orbit sends a lander to
the surface to prove that we can get to
the surface of Mars successfully once
we've shown that the second part of the
mission is to land a rover on Mars
the rover mission fundamentally our
science objective is to look for life
past or present the facility that we're
in at the moment to recall the Mars yard
because the signal delay to Mars can be
such a long time we need to make our
Rover intelligent enough to be able to
drive itself around on Mars and to be
able to do that we need to be able to
test it in a Mars like environment if we
do find methane on Mars that is a good
indicator that either something
geological like volcanic activity or
something biological like the breakdown
of chemicals by bacteria is going on a
Mars either of those would be really
exciting from a scientific perspective
because neither are really things that
we expect to find on modern-day Mars the
biggest thing about this robe that we've
never done before is the drill so our
drill can drill down two meters below
the surface that's a vast difference
from just scraping the surface and
taking samples from the surface there
and that's exactly where we need to be
looking for life so that would be
interesting for scientists but also
answers that fundamental question for
human beings of are we alone in the
universe